[Musica]
il dito prodotti da stiro vive in un
magnifico posto alla la cartiera in
questo talk vi racconteremo come un
lavoro artigianale può aiutare a
risolvere un problema sociale
chi è che di voi sa cucire a macchina
una riga bella dritta lui io no in
questi ultimi anni si è molto parlato
del tema dell'inclusione lavorativa dei
migranti parliamo di richiedenti asilo
persone arrivate in italia fuggite da
situazioni pericolosissime e qui accolte
in centri d'accoglienza in tutta la
penisola
queste persone rimanevano lungo tempo
mesi anche anni anni in attesa della
risposta alla loro domanda di asilo la
nostra organizzazione in quegli anni a
gestito tra le altre cose alcuni centri
di accoglienza ci rendevamo conto della
frustrazione di queste persone per la
difficoltà che si trovava nella nel
trovare un lavoro questo veniva anche
aggravato dalla delle richieste
economiche delle famiglie di origine ci
siamo chiesti che cos'è che possiamo
fare che possiamo offrire loro una
formazione che gli aiuti a trovare un
lavoro di più si possono creare dei veri
e propri posti di lavoro tante idee sono
circolate tante cose sono state anche
fatte poi c'è stata un'occasione
particolare ethical fashion un programma
delle nazioni unite che sostiene gli
artigiani del sud del mondo mettendoli a
contatto con i grandi buyer
internazionali ci ha chiesto di
partecipare
alla sfilata generation africa degli
stilisti africani emergenti a pitti
immagine uomo a firenze nel 2016
chiedendo 5 richiedenti asilo come
modelli ma nico van cos'è sta cosa cosa
strana
la cosa era un po poteva essere
scioccante poteva essere poi alla fine
abbiamo deciso di accettare e questo ci
ha proiettato nel mondo dell'alta moda
un po passo un po particolare ma non ci
rendevamo conto in effetti del dl
clamore che questo evento avrebbe
suscitato tanti giornali internazionali
tanti media ne hanno parlato dalla cnn
al new york times new york times ecco
che allora abbiamo avuto un'intuizione
perché non proviamo ad offrire ad alcuni
di loro un una formazione ad un mestiere
nobile complesso come quello della moda
come quello della dell'alta moda e
l'artigianato ci sembrava un'idea un po
folle poi chiedemmo chi di voi vuole
partecipare
io ho avuto la voglia di provare sono
arrivato nel 2016 dal burkina faso
fuggendo da una città sony molto
pericolosa sono passato in libia dove ho
lavorato e sono in stato trattato come
uno schiavo o subito delle violenze
poi sono riuscito a fuggire
ho fatto una traversata in una piccola
barca con 150 persone siamo e stati
salvati e sbarcati in sicilia
ero molto impaurito e preoccupato per il
futuro
poi per fortuna sono è stato accolto qua
a bologna ho cominciato subito a
studiare l'italiano in sentivo un
escluso ma avevo dell'aspirazione e
tante speranze così che sono entrato nel
primo gruppo di migranti informazioni ci
hanno chiesto se volevamo trasferirci a
barsa porto dove era è stato allestito
il laboratorio di formazione alla
sartoria e pelletteria
io ho sempre amato il mondo della moda
anche in africa ho fatto il salto era la
cosa che mi ha motivato a partecipare al
progetto
allora avevamo da una parte un problema
quello dell'inclusione lavorativa ma
dall'altra avevamo tante energie tanti
desideri come già raccontato bassirou e
allora dovevamo concretizzare un'idea
quella grazie
sono molto emozionato faccio una fatica
bestiale però andiamo avanti grazie a
gabbia dopo buoni quella di rendere il
lavoro artigianale altamente qualificato
un'occasione di inclusione per migranti
e persone svantaggiate
nasce quindi un impresa sociale che è
anche sostenibile perché come vedete
utilizza scarti di produzione sono
pellami eccezionali a non è che siano
che sono donati da grandi marchi della
moda che ci ci aiutano questa impresa
sta in piedi
comincia a produrre funziona ma ci sono
tante difficoltà da affrontare perché il
mestiere dell'artigiano pellettiera non
si improvvisa ci vogliono degli anni per
poter produrre un prodotto impeccabile e
quindi se tanto lavoro dall'altra parte
anche le nostre competenze professionali
erano ed esperienze erano in un altro
ambito erano nell'ambito del sociale
legato alla committenza pubblica una
cosa molto diversa non era un'impresa
troppo difficile lo era però ora che
stiamo riuscendo e vi e scegliamo come
fare impresa è una cosa pazzesca
difficile e allora abbiamo dovuto
fissare alcuni presupposti per poter
avere una guida nel nostro lavoro
il primo presupposto sicuramente quello
forse banale è la sostenibilità
economica dell'impresa sociale non è
così banale
e allora che cosa bisogna fare con una
grande concretezza
bisogna cercare dei clienti creare
partnership che siano durature nel tempo
per strutturare un lavoro una produzione
bisogna cercare quelle aziende che si
cominciano a sentire il tema della
responsabilità sociale d'impresa e della
creazione di valore condiviso nel
territorio e sono sempre di più un
report dell'osservatorio socialis si
dice che la 85 delle imprese con più di
80 dipendenti si impegni iniziative di
responsabilità sociale con un fatturato
di circa un miliardo e mezzo
allora abbiamo visto che perché bisogna
acquistare da un'impresa sociale perché
si fa una scelta etica di sostenere un
insieme di valori che hanno un impatto
sia all'esterno cioè nei confronti degli
stakeholder e dei clienti ma anche
all'interno nei confronti dei dipendenti
del personale che si appassiona ai
progetti e questo noi l'abbiamo visto
con una grande casa di moda difatti
abbiamo avuto alcuni giorni di lavoro
con la responsabile della qualità che ha
supervisionato il nostro lavoro dandoci
consigli preziosi e alla fine dei due
giorni ha detto che quella esperienza è
stata fondamentale per lei per ritrovare
l'energia creativa e ravvivare la
motivazione nel suo lavoro
questa persona e sta continuando ad
aiutarci è straordinaria per noi il
secondo presupposto è un'apertura verso
l'esterno
noi facciamo parte del terzo settore
quell'insieme di organizzazioni
che producono beni e servizi di natura
sono di natura privata ma non producono
beni e servizi pubblici e collettivi è
un settore in cui ci sono delle regole
molto codificate si fa fatica a uscire
dal proprio linguaggio
e invece bisogna andare verso l'esterno
bisogna aprirsi al nuovo
certo c'è una grande
in lontananza tra un in pietra
un'impresa sociale che impiega persone
vulnerabili da una multinazionale della
moda
questo è sicuro ma non bisogna avere
paura di dialogare attrezzandosi
cercando le competenze necessarie con
dei professionisti di quel settore
noi per esempio abbiamo degli artigiani
con tanti anni di esperienza che possono
dialogare con le persone di quei mondi
lontani dal nostro con una grande
attenzione una spasmodica attenzione
alla qualità per fare per non per non
cedere alla qualità per non arrivare a
fare dei prodotti scarsi che possono
essere acquistati solo per la buona
causa
infatti per la formazione abbiamo avuto
come formatori due artigiani specialisti
francesco e katia c'è chi hanno dato
molto umano perché non avevano mai
lavorato con i migranti però hanno messo
dentro le loro competenze indiscussa e
specifica sono stati abbastanza severe e
questo ha creato un pò di fatica per noi
per ora da garanzia sulla qualità non
parla meglio l'italiano di me è
veramente straordinario
il terzo presupposto è un'attenzione
alla vulnerabilità dei lavoratori è
evidente abbiamo parlato di traumi sono
persone che hanno le famiglie lontane si
ritrovano in italia in totale autonomia
con la necessità del reddito e della
situazione abitativa possono nascere
tante incomprensioni
occorre occorre una forse una una forte
attenzione e una presa in carico delle
fragilità con una professionalità ed
empatia l'empatia è fondamentale ma
anche con uno sguardo al territorio alle
relazioni sociali e personali alle reti
che si possono attivare all'interno
della comunità questo è molto vero le
nostre vite sono cambiate dopo che siamo
andati abitare a lama di reno
una sera siamo andati a vedere uno
spettacolo a marzabotto e io mi sono
appassionato al teatro ho contattato la
compagnia mi hanno detto di ritornare
non parlavo bene italiano mi hanno
aiutato a migliorare facendomi ripetere
le cose durante le prove fare parti di
una fare patti di una compagnia
territorio territorio scusate molto
emozionato
[Applauso]
le varie parti fare parte di una
compagnia del territorio
mi crea mi crea delle legami che mi
rendono sicuro di me mi rafforzano mi
fanno sentire partiti della comunità e
mi sento riconosciuto anche dire vero il
lavoro manuale che aiuta ad andare al di
là delle barriere linguistiche
ad esempio il mio collega sei tu che ha
il maggior difficoltà di parlare
l'italiano
ma è il più bravo a cucire ma si esprime
così e tutti i conti lo invidiamo per
questa sua abilità ciao sahidulla una
cosa fondamentale questa che abbiamo
capito il valore del lavoro artigianale
come un linguaggio universale che
permette a tutti di esprimersi al di là
delle barriere che ci possono essere tra
le persone ripensando a quello che
abbiamo che abbiamo fatto
mi viene in mente la visita di papa
francesco a bologna nell'ottobre del
al centro d'accoglienza mattei ti
ricordi bassi rossi si disse i migranti
sapete che cosa siete voi voi siete dei
lottatori di speranza voi dove voi
cercate qualcuno che scommetta su di voi
che vi aiuti e che vi aiuti a creare il
vostro futuro
io devo ringraziare alle persone che
hanno e scommesso su di me e mi auguro
che qui tra queste persone che sia
qualcuno che sta provando a rispondere
alle speranze anche di tanti altri
grazie
[Applauso]